hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer and provides
content for new and aspiring software
engineers and today it's been a solid
one year since i graduated from flatiron
school which is bananas it is quite
absurd quite rude and so i wanted to do
a one-year reflection i remember when i
was trying to pick hoodies boot camps
and see
okay what do people have to say about
these boot camps and everything i really
relied on videos like this to help steer
me in the right direction and so it's
quite the honor that i get to do one for
you all now and so yes let's get to it
so really the largest question that is
probably on your mind is whether or not
i got a job afterwards and the answer is
yes i work with homeboy right over there
if you see that that's check i work at
dreamworks animation studios i'm a
software engineer there and i've been
working there for about three months now
but if you do the math three months ago
was summer of 2021 i graduated october
of 2020 and so where
that time what was going on so i
graduated october of 2020 and got my job
like a year out so i got a job in
october and it wasn't set to start until
the following summer which was summer of
2021. that being said i did have other
offers that were starting sooner my
first offer i got the day of my bootcamp
graduation there's a couple of offers
happening more throughout that same
month and so i just happened to choose
the job that was the most far out
because it was the one that excited me
the most but in between that time i did
do other development work i did some us
ui testing i did some commerce cloud
development and whatnot and so overall i
don't see it as like
oh
it took a year to start working after
boot camp i don't see it like that
because it was a choice i could have
chosen to start working immediately
after if i had chosen a different
company a different offer so yes i've
been working for three months now and i
feel like the next question that should
be on people's minds i don't know if it
is but to me this is the next question
is
if
boot camp well
prepared me prepared me well
for
my job if
i feel like i was well prepared well
versed in languages and set up for
success
and for me
let me let me say that as well this is
all just me don't be out here like
nothing i'm saying is bible okay this is
all just me
and for me
yes yes it very much did and here is why
this i think is a more
unique situation i'm in so i
work at dreamworks and my task for the
last you know three to two to three
months has been really just overhauling
a web app that had been created before i
got there but it was pretty more bare
bones so my task has been building it up
more adding more features to adding more
processes to it completely redesigning
it from like the ground up and
everything and so because of that
that's a lot of what we did at flatirons
we would every three to four weeks
create web apps from scratch and
completely learn new languages use the
skills and functions and whatnot we
learned during classes to build these
web apps from the ground up and that's
what i'm doing right now and especially
when you think about the
piece of not knowing languages until
like six hours before and now you're
trying to build a web app with that
language that's really the situation i'm
in we at my work or at least in
my specific project i'm using python and
flask which is a python micro framework
and i have never touched those languages
before oh that's a lot i had touched
python before but it didn't really go
out too well and in boot camp we focus
on javascript so i touched it before but
i never actually developed or coded with
it and so i was very scared coming into
my first
day knowing okay so they
expect python how do i
how do i do this but it was really funny
because it took me maybe i don't even
know an hour to pick up python because
it is very similar to javascript and you
i don't know if you all hear that thing
of just know one language really well
and you are way
more set up for success rather than
knowing there's a tiny bit of a bunch of
different languages and so with bootcamp
we knew like one to two languages really
well in learning we had started with
vanilla javascript and moved on to react
and we knew ruby as a back end and so
come time for work and
i i was able to really hit the ground
running because the logic is pretty much
the same and so for me it set me up
super well for the current project i'm
in right now because it really is
building kind of from the ground up
which is what we did constantly at
bootcamp now that being said where it
didn't set me up so well
was in understanding other people's code
or
knowing how to start on a project that's
already been there because that's why i
say i'm in a unique situation where my
first project is
kind of doing this whole thing from the
ground up where most people they're the
new person but the code has been there
and it'll keep being there no matter if
that person is there or not and so there
ends up being this problem where it's
okay how do i
come in here in chapter 12 season 5 as
new character and make meaningful
contributions to all of this and so
that's where i feel like they didn't
prep so well because
truly
thinking back everything we did
was
from the ground up nothing was based on
already existing code and so if you want
that experience it's really on you to
ask okay who wants to either like pair
program or practice by hopping onto open
source and contributing that way because
those people the projects have been
there and you're new so it's a good way
to kind of dabble a bit without fearing
that you're going to lose your job for
it and so you really have to
make that effort on your own to get that
practice and so that's where i feel like
i'm not as well versed in and so it
really does take the support of your
team to help you through that process
now of okay this is the code base this
is what they've been working on this is
what the code looks like that's another
thing reading other people's code
not very much prep in that again it goes
back to
you yourself being like okay i'm going
to take time to pair programs so i can
see how other people code or have these
partners or study groups or and whatnot
and to try to read other people's code
so that i can practice that later on
because code i think some people kind of
think that like oh code is code if you
know how to read code it's like reading
words you know like a word is a word no
matter what book it's in but with coding
that's not really how it goes there's a
billion and one ways to put out the
exact same solution and your way of
thinking and your way processing and
your way of solving solution can be so
different from another person even
though it completes the exact same
problem and so you need to be able to
switch your brain so that you can
understand and interpret of the other
people's code so you can get the job
done and so with that i highly recommend
taking that time on your own taking the
initiative on your own to seek out those
opportunities to read and learn from
other people's
overall i absolutely love where i am i'm
so so grateful for that and for
flattering school and my teachers and
mentors and cohort mates and co-workers
if y'all are watching this um
i
am just so grateful for where i am i'm
so grateful that to i'm so grateful to
myself for being brave enough to take
the leap of a coding boot camp in a time
where it seems like the craziest of
ideas um just to me and
i am really happy of where i am and so
this is not an advertisement to finance
school or coding boot camps at all it's
not sponsored i just want to do some
yeah reflecting because it's been a year
and it's been
a hell of a year at times and
i am really proud of
what this year and the time at boot camp
has brought on and so i really wanted to
share that and provide that perspective
to you all and so yeah think about if
coding bootcamp is right for you i have
tons of videos on that so feel free to
browse to my channel ask me any
questions you like and i will get back
to you as soon as i can but yes thank
you so much for watching and i'll see
you all later bye